you are working cold fusion PD
[Music]
hi to gogo here and welcome to another
ColdFusion video in my living memory
whenever you wanted to watch a video it
had to be on VCR and then later came the
DVD player and then we moved over to
cable networks and now there's YouTube
but only just 25 years ago
streaming videos over the Internet was
pretty much the stuff of science fiction
the YouTube phenomenon in of itself has
only been around for 10 years and
already has definitely changed the world
the sheer size and influence of YouTube
is truly mind-boggling in this video
we'll take a look at exactly how this
platform rose to prominence and just how
big it is so first of all the size the 7
billion hours of video watched every
month also it will take you four
straight days of watching just to view
the amount of video uploaded every 60
seconds but surprisingly 80 percent of
all YouTube views are outside of the
United States of America in terms of
size on the web YouTube is the third
most visited site on the Internet and
the second largest search engine on the
internet so this gives you a very quick
glimpse into how big YouTube actually is
right now but where did all this come
from and how did this happen
well let me tell you a little story
in one way it all starts with Elon Musk
yes that guy that is planning to send
people to Mars and already has his own
space company and the same guy who
created the all-electric car company
Tesla as impressive as this was prior to
all of this
Elon Musk also co-founder a website
called PayPal and as it turns out three
employees of PayPal would go on to
change the world
their names are Chad Hurley Steve Chen
and jawed Karim after their days at
PayPal they were interested in creating
a video dating website called TuneIn
hookup it was a site where people could
upload videos of themselves in order to
find dates and as you could guess it
didn't really work all too low as most
people weren't really interested in the
idea but as it so often happens with
these things
serendipity would strike one day jared
happened to notice how hard it was to
find a video of Janet Jackson's wardrobe
malfunction anywhere on the Internet
this sparked an idea and the lack of
James wardrobe malfunction was realized
as a market need and the solution to
this need would change the world they
just needed the right formula and the
perfect formula was found within the
existing video sharing site TuneIn
hookup whose name was later changed to
YouTube the website was founded on
February 14th 2005 in a humble room
above a pizza shop in California the
first video was titled me at the zoo and
it was by Jared Karim uploaded on April
23rd 2005
wasn't long before YouTube had his first
1 million hit video this happened in
September 2005 and it was actually a
Nike app this ad featured the Brazilian
player Ronaldinho and it made Nike one
of the first companies to embrace
YouTube's promotional potential by
November 2005 the site had already
received 3.5 million dollars in finisher
capital in June of 2006 NBC and YouTube
struck a deal this helped the
traditional media company into the
digital age after this it wasn't long
before the site caught the attention of
Google and in October 2006 the site was
acquired for a cool 1.65 billion dollars
with the co-founders of the site and we
just wanted to say thank you today we
have some exciting news for you we've
been acquired by Google thanks thanks to
every one of you guys that have been
contributing to YouTube the community we
would be wouldn't be anywhere close to
where we are without the help of this
community
thank at the time Google called it the
next step in the evolution of the
internet it was a pretty bold thing to
say at the time because the company only
had 65 employees things just kept going
from strength to strength for YouTube
and that year YouTube was one of the
fastest growing sites on the entire
Internet there's obviously something
special here this was really just the
beginning the site was about to become a
so personal for many individuals around
the world in May 2007 the YouTube
Partner Program came into the picture
this personally changed the lives of
many people for the first time YouTube
made it possible for everyday people to
turn their hobbies into a business about
a year later the most successful users
were earning six-figure incomes from
YouTube
in the same year 7 out of the 16
presidential candidates announced their
campaigns via YouTube and in July
YouTube and CNN hosted their first
presidential debate featuring citizens
submitted video questions this was also
the first time into bait history where
user-generated video drove the debate
for some reason this somewhat reminds me
of the first televised presidential
debate between Nixon and Kennedy in 1960
at the time many said that if it wasn't
for the televised session Kennedy would
have never been elected so the question
is did YouTube actually play a part in
history this time continuing with the
story in August of 2007 Google finally
decided it was time to start making
money and rolled out the first
advertisements after this it wasn't long
before YouTube truly became mainstream
in 2009 Congress and the Vatican
launched their YouTube channels and by
2011 features such as YouTube's live
streaming allowed real-time footage of
anything from rural wedding to the
Olympics to live concerts on news
coverage in the same year it became
clear that YouTube could do even bigger
things it could influence world history
during the 2011 Arab Spring YouTube
played an instrumental role in
disseminating messages of freedom and
democracy it demonstrated the major
cultural movements could now be
influenced by social media on a
different note and in the same year the
channel majestic casual was founded
some say that this channel influenced
internet music culture with an acute
taste for various types of cutting-edge
future music of various genres it
brought the music into the limelight
which is now heard everywhere from 2012
onwards you've never really looked back
over the years every few months new
features have been added to the dismay
or joy of many but regardless saw the
exponential growth of the website it
really has become its own living
breathing culture which is amazing for
the short amount of time that has really
been around in full force so that's all
well and good but what other interesting
things are there about YouTube just how
big is it now well it's bigger than TV
according to Google executive chairman
Eric Schmidt he already serves the
YouTube is replacing TV watching as a
whole he goes on to say that the future
of YouTube is now this was in reference
to YouTube having passed 1 billion
unique visitors every month but he says
it's not finished yet he goes on to say
wait until he gets a 6 billion or 7
billion unique users a month but that
was two years ago and now everyone is
starting to realize just how big YouTube
is even the TV advertisers advertisers
are now starting to turn from TV to
YouTube and one of those ways is through
Google's preferred program where
exclusive advertisers which many of them
are from TV can choose to advertise on
premium YouTube channels not only this
but some very real celebrities have
actually made their start from YouTube
apologetically one that comes to mind is
Justin Bieber but apart from that we
have shows like broad city and
workaholics which were to mirroring
concept shows that got their start from
YouTube skits and now they have full
seasons on primetime TV and are both
enjoying a lot of success but that's not
all some quite interesting phenomena is
happening just by the sheer amount of
video that's on there when you just have
so many people uploading videos some
strange things are bound to happen a
large number of people who have started
to upload their old VHS tapes digitally
and because there are just so many
people doing this we can already
construct entire decades of TV so much
so that if you were a couch potato 20
years ago that never went outside and
just sat down and
TV all day the simulation that we get
from all these YouTube videos can
already be pretty accurate maybe
wondering what I'm talking about here
and how do I know this well this is my
case in point right here there exists a
very clever website that was made to
mimic the TV reality of the 1970s 1980s
and 1990s the sites are called my 70s TV
my 80s TV and my 90's TV respectively
and on here you can watch comedy
commercials drama game shows movies
music news specials sports talk shows
movie trailers and just everything from
a particular year there's more videos
being added all the time but already it
works like an actual TV of the decade I
may be alone on this one but I
personally think this is one of the most
amazing things I've ever seen on the
Internet
it's really like unfiltered history so
just finishing off there's so much I can
say about YouTube but it's clear that
the community is very vibrant as there's
new forms of infotainment which channels
such as Vsauce or veritasium or even
channels for straight learning such as
sixty symbols or crash course there's
everything from hilarious prank videos
with channels such as big doors TV or
Andrew Hales amazing special effects
with corridor digital or Freddy view or
just straight-up comedy with Smosh
owners pranks and nigahiga community
channel or even the stranger comedy of
howtobasic who by the way actually lives
around the corner from me in Perth I've
actually did used that by some of the
surroundings in his videos and I found
that absolutely hilarious coming to a
close YouTube definitely has changed the
world politically personally for the
lives of many and collectively in the
way we communicate with each other and
tend to consume media throughout society
it's all very very interesting and only
time will tell whether its platform goes
in another 10 years video on demand has
never been so diverse and has never been
so good so looking at the big picture
all of this really just started from 3
good friends realizing that there was no
existing way of sharing an embarrassing
video of Jenna
it's funny the way things go anyway this
has been to gogo
and you've been watching cold fusion
don't forget to leave a comment give a
thumbs up and subscribe if you're new
thanks for watching and I'll see you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
hey guys to get here just want to thank
you guys for watching my YouTube
documentary or the documentary on
YouTube I just think it's kind of
fascinating that this whole phenomena
which I'm even a part of started because
three guys just had a good idea and just
really went for it so it's a really cool
story when you think about it and I just
thought I'd like to share that with you
guys but yeah as you saw by the end of
that video the Vox is launched it is
still being worked on sorry those taken
so long you know the pipeline that we've
got is only really small I've only got
me as a designer and the code are
working on the implementation of the
boxis launcher and he's busy with some
other client work as well over the past
couple of months and I've just started
full-time work as well which is another
reason why the video uploads haven't
been as regular so I'm still trying to
find that balance between uploading
videos and actually working full-time so
you know don't worry guys like things
will get smoothed out in a while so I
just want to thank you for your patience
for you guys who have been hanging in
there yeah I think that's all I really
had to say so yeah you guys have a good
one and I'll see you again soon for the
next video cheers guys